tonight Mark the start of day two of the
annual EDC Festival at the Las Vegas
Motor Speedway 8 news now reporter Brian
will tells us how the festival goers
were getting to the event and explains
the impact to your drive through this
weekend
it's one of the biggest traffic events
that southern Nevada has every year
that's EDC we spoke to folks about how
this year Compares and if they're taking
the shuttle or sitting in traffic like
these folks behind me
we did drive after that I said never
again so it's been the shuttle the
second year and it's the shuttle that
I'm heading to right now Kayla Morgan is
one of the expected 500 000 attendees at
this year's EDC it's her third year and
she doesn't even bother driving to the
event anymore we were in traffic for
about two and a half hours we tried to
make the best of it streamed the live
stream of EDC so we have some music
playing and pretend like we were there
but being stuck in traffic for two hours
kind of was a little Downer EDC 2023
baby Festival goers have the option of
taking a shuttle from one of eight
locations to the festival we didn't want
to drive and we heard that they take the
back roads and so it avoids some of the
traffic when it cuts time in half we
don't have to wait too long it's
convenient and if you're going to drive
the best suggestion is to carpool and
make sure to fill up with gas before
making the trip North for others they
don't want to be stuck in that traffic
again I picked a hotel that was
convenient for the shuttle stop that I
wanted so it all worked out I got the
hotel I got the shuttle I'm on my way
they'll drop me back off at the end of
the night and I'll go to sleep and it
will be great the busiest times for
congestion like this is between 6 and 10
p.m when people are arriving at EDC and
4 a.m and 10 a.m when people are leaving
reporting in North Las Vegas Brian will
eight news now the traffic congestion
should clear up after Monday morning's
commute at the end of that Festival if
you're heading out this weekend you can
find a full list of road restrictions on
our website 8newsnow.com